peu
même si cela on est claude m barre avis
c'est légal de parents tchadien est
considéré comme l'un des premiers avec
ntm et iam avoir démocratisé le rap
les rappeurs pur et dur dit ce qu'il a à
spa 10 voire cry
même si cela poursuit sa route trace son
chemin d'album en album
le qui sème le vent récolte le tempo en
1991 à maxis tous d'énormes succès qui
lui apporte la consécration
internationale à l'occasion de la sortie
aux éditions panama de solar hesse ouest
un livre de photographies de philippe
bordas elle si cela on nous propose un
journal intime où il revient sur ses
origines ses influences trace un
parallèle étonnant entre le rap et le
foot qui pratique depuis toujours
en virtuose sans oublier de nous
rappeler qu'il n'est pas si facile de
conduire une mercedes avec une casquette
de rappeur
je pense très peu maintenant choix de
lunettes spectateurs et une phrase qu'un
15 canam mady et j'aime la répéter les
vrais durs ne danse pas commencé là-bas
dans la ville qu'on l'appelle maisons
alfort quand je vois d'une de pat
marshall ou qui fait vibrer son corps
elle me dit
les no mercy 7 l'agera prime moi je
trouvais pensé avoir trouvé quelque
chose de très marrant des villes
africaines peapod on était à dakar et
quelques années et il ya un homme qui
arrive et qui nous a dit qu rap ça
voulait dire réapprendre à parler on est
en afrique alors on pense à on pense aux
griots on pense aux comptes on pense à
plein de choses et c'est la meilleure
définition que j'ai que j'ai que je n'en
ai appris réapprendre à parler ma mère
et mon beau du tchad qui est un bail
beaucoup c'est
au sud je suis très régulièrement
retournée au sénégal mais jamais au
tchad et aujourd'hui je crois que c'est
leur beaucoup de démunis sens de ce
qu'ils écoutent et marc ma mère il ya eu
la musique zaïroise qui étaient à la
mode dans les années 80 soukouss des
trucs avec leurs guitares les roomba
après il y avait lui la musique
sénégalaise qui est revenu en force avec
youssou ndour mais elle existait aussi à
l'époque
des sons cuba après les les ivoiriens
sont arrivés avec des nouveautés une
danse toutes et tous les mois est un
nouveau concept où les mois qu'on fait
on une idée ça c'est le stylisme pur
société des ambianceurs et des personnes
élégantes
c'est aussi une aspect que faut montrer
aussi à nous ça on a droit aussi d'avoir
du style et de la classe parler j'ai
écouté tous à une superbe fille je
repense à l aller one au corps n'est pas
ni à sa boulimie de fraises framboises
de myrtille assez des myrtes utile à son
style pacotille je suis alors
l'impression de jouer au football c'est
vrai j'étais très vif très résistant
très rapide très technique prêts
d'honneur de ballons aussi c'est à dire
je marque et très peu mais je donnais
des bons ballons
il s'appliquera du caviar j'adore moi
j'aimais le bouge dans le foot et de rap
ou l'écriture c'est très bien
j'en suis sûr j'aime aussi que le papier
la façon dont ses écrits qui est quelque
chose pour tous à l'origine c'était
peut-être mon rapport au foot ça nulle
envie de district de belles choses il ya
plein de choses qui vont avec le rap et
de l'homme est là le carton des fois
quand on dépasse les doigts on sait
jamais quand est ce qu'on dit qu'on
dépasse parce que il faut qu'on ait dû
du panache qu'on le fasse réagir les
gens alors est ce qu ont dépassé ce
qu'on dépasse pas ce qu'on va dans la
polémique est ce qu'on n'y va pas et
c'est ça donc les cartons alors des fois
c'est jaune après ça devient rouge et à
l'entraînement systématique et les
rappeurs s'entraîne chez eux
car ils font croire que c'est du
freestyle ou qu'ils ont trouvé une idée
mais sa mâture dans leur tête
alors l'entraîneur sait quoi amorcer un
baladeur mp3 et puis on va écouter des
disques à écouter tenter de refaire par
contre y'a pas d'arbitrage c'est la
pagaille contrôle doute quelque peu
farfelue
j'ai peut-être trop belle voiture parce
quand je suis sortie ils ont pensé mais
les volets c'est sûr sans même si je
suis à côté de chez moi dans une voiture
à peu près banale qui ressemble à ça et
un contrôle de police qui tourne mais
vraiment très très mal parce que
casquette et traîné par terre sans
raison valable mais réellement sans
raison valable
avec ma femme qui reste dans la voiture
c'est c'est pas très beau alors si je
parle outrage à agent et surtout gave
c'est à dire penser que parce qu'on a
une casquette on n'a pas le droit de
conduire dans le viiie le 17e et 16e
arrondissements c'est surtout ça qui
s'est passé la police doit être
républicaine il faut qu'elles agissent à
peu près normalement ma voiture n'est
pas volé quoi c'est la mienne
et j'ai le permis
rafika d'un seul ne peut pas casser la
doua voilà le genre de cent ans que nous
apprend la barre pour soigner la maladie
la première fois que j'allais un moment
dans mon pays de naissance y donc à
dakar c'était vraiment un choc
c'était vraiment un choc mais peu de
positivité l'adéquation avec avec ce que
j'entendais
se sentait moi même puis mes acolytes on
sentait vraiment chez nous on avait tous
ses étés des des fruits du béton de là
on a trouvé un peu des racines là bas on
l'a retrouvé un peu d'afrique c'était
vraiment on été nourris quand on
rentrait ici nous var périphérique porte
de bagnolet
on était fort c'est un crève incroyable
il est très important d'aller à leur
rencontre le monde là-bas et voilà quoi
il y avait beaucoup d'américains qui
nous quittent ils vont l'annoncer il
clinton selon le parquet
les gens quoi et tous ces gens là ils
sont venus pour visiter la maison des
esclaves
ouais c'est bien qu'ils aient des
bouquins c'est bien qu'ils d'aller à
gorée savoir ce qui s'est passé et il
faut pas il faudrait pas que les télés
les 300 ans les 10 730 deviennent des
années 2006 c'est avec l'expérience du
passé qu'on va dans un avenir si
possible positive qui si le montre la
route
[Musique]
cauchemar de darwin il faut à tout prix
aller le voir
il est sorti en dvd actuellement ça
raconte l'histoire de la perche du nil
et les ramifications avec avec les
ventes d'armes mais aussi avec alors
qu'iliad d'opulence il ya des gens qui
n'ont rien à manger juste à côté
je ne peux pas en dire plus c'est une
ouverture et il faut et il faut y aller
j'ai pas encore vu non mais je veux
l'acheter à chaque fois est ici
[Musique]